GILBERT STRANG: OK.
This video is about the
third of the great trio
of partial
differential equations.
Laplace's equation
was number one.
That's called an
elliptic equation.
The heat equation
was number two.
That's called a
parabolic equation.
Now we reach the wave equation.
That's number three, and it's
called a hyperbolic equation.
So somehow the three
equations remind us
of ellipses, parabolas,
and hyperbolas.
They have different
types of solutions.
Laplace's equation, you
solve it inside a circle
or inside some closed region.
The heat equation and
the wave equation, time
enters, and you're
going forward in time.
The heat equation is first
order in time, du dt.
And the wave equation, the
full-scale wave equation,
is second order in time.
That stands for the second
derivative, d second u
dt squared.
And it matches the
second derivative
in space with a velocity
coefficient c squared.
I'm in one-dimensional space.
If I were in three
dimensions, where we really
have sound waves and light
waves and all the most important
things in life, then there
would be a uxx and a uyy
and a uzz, second derivatives
in all the space directions.
But that's good enough to do 1D.
So what are the
differences, first of all,
between the heat equation
and wave equation?
So I'll say heat
versus wave equations.
What are the sort of
biggest differences?
The heat, the signal
travels infinitely fast.
Under the wave
equation, the signal
travels with finite
velocity, and that velocity
is that number c with speed c.
So fortunately, for sound
waves, the wave comes to us,
or when I'm speaking
to you, my voice
is traveling out
to the microphone
at the speed of
sound, the speed c.
And actually, another good
thing is after it gets there,
it goes on, and it
goes by the point
and doesn't just stay there
messing up the future sounds.
It travels.
It dies out.
Whereas-- well, the heat.
So let me try to
give an example.
Suppose the initial condition
is a delta function.
So if u equals a delta
function, a point source,
which is quite normal.
A point source of heat,
something really hot,
or a point source
of sound, my voice.
So it's that at t equals 0.
Then for the heat
equation, there's
a famous solution to
the heat equation.
Remember, the heat equation
is du dt equal uxx,
first derivative in time.
And the solution that starts
from the delta function?
Oh, do I know what it is?
I think there's a 1 over--
there's a square root of 4
pi t.
There's an e to the
minus x squared over 4t.
I think perhaps that's it.
Perhaps that's it.
So what do I see from that?
I see big damping out.
I see immediate travel.
As soon as time is just
a little beyond 0, then
for every x we get an answer,
but it's an extremely,
extremely small answer.
e to the minus x squared
is tailing off to
0 incredibly fast.
So that's a very small answer.
Very little of the heat
immediately gets very,
very quickly across the ocean.
But in theory, a
little bit does.
Whereas for the
wave equation, it
takes time to cross the ocean.
We have a tsunami.
We have a wave.
It gets there.
It reaches the other side.
And actually, at the--
it's very important.
What is the speed of
that wave to tell people
about a tsunami that's
coming, and you can actually
do it, which you couldn't
do for the heat equation.
So for the wave
equation, what comes out
of a delta function in 1D?
Well, a wave goes to the right,
and a wave goes to the left.
That's what happens.
And those waves are 1/2 of
a delta function each way.
So the solution is 1/2
of a delta function
that's traveling.
I see that-- let me write
down the other half that's
traveling the other
way-- delta at x plus ct.
That's a cool solution.
So that means the
sound in 1D, the sound,
half of it takes
off in one direction
and half in the other direction.
And what happens in each
direction is a spike of sound.
You don't hear anything,
then at a particular time,
depending on your
position x, there's
a particular time when
you get 0 in there,
and you hear the signal.
And then as soon as time goes
past that, it's past you.
So you get a big shock, and
it comes to you with speed c.
If you look at that
expression x minus ct,
it's telling you that
the speed of the wave
in dx dt for the wave is c.
OK.
So that's a contrast for a very
particular initial condition--
a big wall of water, a
big noise, a big bang.
OK.
I want to solve
the wave equation,
study it further for
other initial conditions.
And of course, initial
condition's plural
because the wave equation
is second order in time.
So I'm given u at t equals
0 and all x and du dt.
I'm given an
initial distribution
of the wall of
water, shall we say,
and its velocity,
the normal thing.
When I have a
second-order equation,
I'm given an initial condition
and an initial velocity.
And of course, because it's a
partial differential equation,
I'm given those for every x.
So we have functions
instead of just two numbers,
and that's where a Fourier
series can come in.
So we can solve that
by a Fourier series
if we're on a finite--
like a violin string.
You've plucked a
violin string that
starts waves going back
and forth in the string.
They solve the wave equation.
You hear music, great
music if it's a good sound.
Or we could solve it on an
infinite line with no boundary,
as in an essentially infinite
ocean or waves in space.
Light waves in space are
solving the wave equation
with no boundary,
as far as we know.
OK.
So which shall I do?
I'll write the solution
down in free space,
and then I'll write one
down for a violin string.
So in space-- well, it's a
one-dimensional space here.
So this would be minus infinity
less than x less than infinity.
Then what does the solution to
the wave equation look like?
It looks like some function
of plus some function
of x plus ct.
Well, that's exactly the
form that we had here
when they were delta functions.
Here, in general, they don't
have to be delta functions.
I chose that function f and
that function g so that at t
equals 0, I'm good.
So at t equals 0--
so I set t equals 0.
At t equals 0, u of 0 and x
would be f of x plus g of x.
Good.
But that's only one condition,
and I have f and g to find.
So I would also use
du dt at the start.
What's the time derivative?
It's minus c f prime at x.
And the time derivative of this
will be a plus c g prime at x.
OK.
No big deal.
I'm given two functions.
I've got two functions
to find in the answer,
and I've got two equations.
I could solve those for f
and g, and it gives a formula
called d'Alembert's formula,
named after the person who
put this together.
I'd rather go on to the
violin, to a finite string.
OK.
So now I have a
finite string, and I'm
holding u equals 0 at the ends.
OK.
And my solution will
still be functions that
depend on x minus ct waves.
My solution will still be waves.
The solution that I'm
going to write down
comes from a very,
very important method
called separation of variables.
I want to separate x from t.
I need to give you a full video
about separation of variables.
That's the best tool we
have to get solutions
to lots of equations.
So let me just jump to the
form of the solution here.
I'm imagining the violin
string is at rest.
So it starts with--
I'm imagining,
let's say in our
particular problem,
this is 0, the initial velocity.
This is plucked.
The starting position
is-- with your finger
you've moved it off 0.
OK.
What do the solutions
look like, u of t and x?
OK.
They will be a sum of neat,
special, convenient, separated
solutions, with separated
meaning t separated from x.
And I think we would
have cosine of nct.
I'm going to have a sum.
Oh, we'll have a coefficient,
of course, a sub-- well, or b,
or c, or even d.
How about d for a
new letter-- d sub n.
And I think-- well,
let me finish here.
I'm separating that from
I think it would probably
be the sine of nx.
OK.
If we just look at
that for a little bit,
that's the point of this video.
So this is x equals 0.
This is, say, x equal pi.
That's for convenience.
Suppose our violin
string has length pi,
then, I think, that's what
the solution looks like.
It starts from at t equals 0.
At t equals 0, the cosine is 1.
So at t equals 0, this
is an initial condition
that we have to match.
This'll tell us the d's will
be the sum of dn sine nx.
That tells us the d's.
And then we have our answer.
So the initial
condition-- remember,
it's starting at rest.
So the initial velocity
is 0, and that's
why I don't have any sine
t's because I'm starting
with initial velocity 0.
I only have cosines
in the t direction.
But I only have sines
in the x direction
because the violin
string is being held down
at the two ends, and
it's the sine function
that matches that perfectly.
So this is separation of
variables, t separated from x.
And I really have to
do a proper explanation
of that highly important method
of getting solutions like this.
Thank you.